it's not a radical position at this
point in American history to say that
decriminalization or or legalization
ought to occur hi I'm Nick Gillespie
with Reason TV and we're at Seattle temp
fest and we're talking to representative
Dennis Kucinich from Democrat of Ohio
thanks for talking to us what is your
take on marijuana legalization is are we
coming towards a mama where that's going
to happen I think the answer is yes
because the cost of enforcing these laws
is prohibitive because it's been proven
it's not a gateway drug
because you know the American people are
mature enough to be able to make their
own choices this is one area where the
government really should not be
concerned about what people are smoking
as a health problem that's a separate
issue but if somebody has a drug problem
that should be a matter of
hospitalization not incarceration but I
think America has grown to understand
that this intervention through
surveillance and through spying on
people who are users of marijuana that
that has to stop
is this gonna be a bipartisan victory
when marijuana legalization takes place
you've worked with people like Ron Paul
on the other side of the aisle who are
the best allies in the Republican Party
to push this forward there's a number of
libertarians on both sides of the aisle
who understand that this is something
that we shouldn't be knockin our heads
into a wall about it's it's not a
radical position at this point in
American history to say that
decriminalization or or legalization
ought to occur it's not you know I don't
see it as a big deal you've talked about
how in order for social change to happen
people have to go out in the streets
they have to make themselves visible as
way that the civil rights that would you
are you prepared to talk about your use
of marijuana or your use of illegal
drugs as a way of spurring people to be
confident about telling their stories
I'm probably the wrong person to ask to
come forward and testify because I had
never smoked
and I mean anything and I just don't
smoke but to me actually just a personal
freedom issue and just because you know
whether I smoked or not I can still take
a stand for personal freedom Thanks
thank you
you